let's see let's go next - why don't we
go to our caller from the 203 area code
who's calling today from 203 hey David
it's me yes that's you hi
so I'm curious about your take about the
Supreme Court I know recently Bernie
Sanders came out and said that he's
against increasing the number of judges
and Supreme Court yep and but he's Pro
like a circuit of like judges coming
through what was your take on that do
you think I've seen some convincing
arguments about stacking the court
packing the court and increasing the
number of Justices I do also think that
it's one of those things where if if we
do it then it's opening up the door for
them to do it and the the reality is
that right now the left has much more to
lose from not changing the structure of
the Supreme Court because Donald Trump
partially thanks to Mitch McConnell's
obstruction of Merrick garland has
already had two Supreme Court picks and
there is potentially going to be a very
conservative Supreme Court for a long
time so I understand the appeal although
I worry about opening up that door in
terms of the idea of Supreme Court
justices not serving for life I find
that very interesting as well the only
problem is like with all of these things
once you know you are not going to be
serving for life you potentially could
be influenced in terms of how you decide
cases based on whether maybe there is a
party to one of those cases that after
you are no longer on the court you might
consult for or work for or whatever and
it creates a lot of complicated issues
related to conflicts of interest and
recusal so I like a lot of these ideas
and I also recognize some of the
shortfalls of them yeah I've seen some
some proposed bills like I mean judges
and both congressmen and the Senate to
you know like no I get into the
industries out there they leave office
well that's the thing if you link it
with Supreme Court justices if you say
you no longer have a lifetime
appointment but you also have to agree
not to work for any of the industries
whose cases you hear while you're on the
court it becomes almost impossible right
like what are they expected to do
because the Supreme Court hears so many
different cases so I don't know what the
solution is but I think that we we
there's definitely improvements to be
made all right thank you David okay
appreciate the phone call thank you very
much